nobody had ever dealt with with that and
you know with the idea of even losing
him Jennifer Aniston cries over Matthew
Perry's Addiction in this newly
Unearthed interview footage we didn't
know
we you know
we weren't equipped Matthew sits down
with Diane Sawyer for a new interview
with Good Morning America to promote his
Memoir friends lovers and the big
terrible thing and opens up about his
struggles with addiction you know you
get into that uh you get into a place in
your life where you're having a problem
and you either you know lie down about
it or step up to bat and
take your uh take your swing and that's
what I did revealing Jen played a big
part in his road to sobriety she says we
know you're drinking
imagine how scary a moment that was
um and I said how I thought I was hiding
it so well and she said we can smell it
and we can smell it
and
but I wasn't in a position to stop
you know and that's what addiction is
but she was the one that reached out the
most you know a really grateful to her
for that of course the two starred
alongside one another in the hit 90s
sitcom Friends hey
I'm in college and I'm in a band
and in 2004 the year the show ended Jen
got emotional talking about her friend
during a sit-down with Diane after
Matthew's addiction was made public what
doesn't Matthew know
that he's all right
we didn't know
we you know
we weren't equipped we weren't
to deal with it
you know nobody had ever
dealt with with that
and
you know at the idea of even losing him
of course it's no secret the cast was
and is close when they reunited last
year after the show was over at a party
or any any kind of social Gathering if
one of us bumped into each other that
was it that was the end of the night you
just sat with that sat with the person
all night long Jen dished on their bond
there was something that was laid down
at the very very beginning that kind of
went into our neural Pathways that we
instantly it was in our DNA that we were
family we were going to take care of
each other we're the most grateful women
that I know who have been able to be a
part of something like this and the
experience of being back together had
her deep in her feels it was just a real
oh yeah and once her Gates opened then
it was I couldn't shut it off you
couldn't even I didn't plug it I didn't
no nothing I still was just like
generally are you crying as much as me
and she's like yeah it was just the most
emotional thing as for Matthew he's
telling all in his new book confessing
he had a crush on Jen back in the day
that's for sure the actor writes that he
was immediately taken by her but she
declined after he asked her out what am
I gonna do now just pass the tape along
he's not right for the part so if I
suggest to my bosses are going to think
I'm an idiot and that's something they
should learn on their own and while the
actor says he was still attracted to her
they were able to quote sail right past
the past and focus on the fact that we
had both gotten the best job Hollywood
had to offer
foreign